[Music]
you
hello and welcome to our expert
discussion how ai
is changing the dynamics of fintech our
guest today is lizzie chapman the ceo
and co-founder of zest money
zest is the largest and fastest growing
fintech consumer company in
india and it serves
300 million potential customers whose
lives can be changed by access
to consumer credit i'm
stewart creek i'm a marketing manager
here at simply learn and i
will start off by sharing with you how
to
interact with us during this webinar the
q a button will allow you to put in
questions for lizzy to address toward
the end of the session in the q a
do ask all panelists and remember to hit
send
similarly the chat window lets you send
messages to us
make sure that you put in all panelists
or host and presenter
so that we do get um
to see that message otherwise if it
comes privately to host
might not see it um again
hit send for us to see that message
and we will also be doing some
polls during this webinar
that is if i can launch one
[Music]
our first is a pretty simple one
it's just two questions what is your
current job
or job role and how are you feeling
today
let me open that poll
i'll give you about a minute we aren't
going to spend five minutes on this bowl
so we wanted to ask a question we've
been asking
since the pandemic started which is how
are you feeling today
not medically but how are you coping
with
the changes around you
and i'll leave the poll open for just a
few more seconds
you have about 15 seconds to get your
answers in
and we have some managers executives
and students today um not that many
people in currently
in fintech related jobs
the one thing i am glad to see is
that pretty much everybody is thumbs up
or at least in the middle
so that's good to see
now i'm going to introduce lizzie
chapman
who as i mentioned is the
ceo and co-founder of zest money
which is the largest and fastest growing
consumer lending fintech company
in india it is uh she is formerly the
executive director of digibank and
a co-founder of abode bombay
and impasse was country head of
wonga.com so she has a
sterling track record
so welcome lizzy
thank you thank you so much and i'm
shocked to see
that there's only five percent fintech
participation
hopefully if we ran that poll again
tomorrow uh
people will have switched we can convert
some people today on the call
precisely so
um let me start off with a question
you know what's been the biggest trigger
for fintech like zest money
um to power through this pandemic and
survive
it's one of the most challenging times
for business not only in india but
around the world
um and certainly for the financial
services industry so
what worked for you yeah i know it's a
it's a great question and i guess the
topic
on everyone's lips at the moment and
it's been a very bizarre time
in some ways it was the most challenging
experience we've ever had and something
we never imagined we would live through
we had one of the most severe lockdowns
in the world
in india and we had the double whammy of
a lending business
with a moratorium announcement from the
regulator
which makes life very difficult um
but then there was this phenomenal kind
of resurgence
over the last few months and a huge
shift
towards all things digital around the
world and especially in our market
and really an acceleration of what we
always expected would happen
in the financial services industry which
is that really
sharp move towards complete automation
and digitalization
so what helped us what helped us get
through that difficult time and and get
to the light at the end of the tunnel
i think was probably two main factors
one is our customer centricity we always
put the customer first and that meant it
was very easy to make decisions
when times were tough so for example
when the moratorium was announced
um we didn't have to do any analysis we
knew that we would offer it to our
customers
and all we had to do was think about
what was the best way
to communicate and educate them for
example
and because we had a great relationship
with our customers already
they actually were very cooperative uh
very open to discussing any financial
problems they were having
and we managed to sail through on the
kind of risk and
collection side really smoothly i think
the second factor though that really
helped us and hopefully
why we're all here today is that we are
a completely
data centric organization so everything
we do
revolves around data and in difficult
times
there can be no better way to make
decisions quickly
every decision counts and speed of
decision making
is everything and so we were really
fortunate
to have a phenomenal data set to be able
to do things like i'll give you just one
simple example
that hopefully people can relate to when
the lockdowns first hit
and none of us had any idea how severe
this pandemic would be
one thing we needed to do was predict
which of our customer segments
would have the most challenge in keeping
up their repayments
right because that's obviously one of
the biggest risks to our business
and see how we could help them but when
there was no information about the
pandemic about
the potential economic impact etc we had
to create our
own income shock prediction model
so a predictive algorithm that could
look on an individual customer basis
and ascribe a probability to how much
their income
would decline over the next six months
and we built that model very quickly
we deployed it and it proved to be
extremely accurate and the brilliant
thing about being
an ai driven business we're really an ai
first business
is we were ready with models like that
we already had a team that we're
building them
and we could develop that model as we
went along
so as we got more inputs as we got more
data as we got information about
hotspots for example
literally to the pin code level this
data could teach the model and it would
almost become self-learning
so over time even the accuracy of our
decisions was improving
as we were getting more data back into
the system
does that does that make sense yeah it
certainly makes sense i mean one of the
fantastic things about uh ai and machine
learning is the more data you have the
better
the model becomes
exactly so um
you you have a business model that's
fully automated
that's right yeah exactly and that's um
you know another thing that obviously
helped at this time so if you think
about when the moratorium was first
announced
a lot of traditional lenders had to
basically you know
tell their branch manager tell their
frontline staff
what would be the policy because we had
a completely automated platform we could
immediately update
all of our communications our app our
website
almost in a matter of minutes with our
policy
and we could use technology to create
the smoothest and easiest ways for
customers
to either pause their loan or keep up
their repayments during that difficult
time
we also don't believe in cash we've
never handled cash in our business
and we used to get a lot of pushback
from that in the early days people would
say how can you operate in india and not
handle cash but we felt that it was
synonymous with
um you know being a completely automated
business we really wanted to do
end-to-end automation and so during the
pandemic
we just doubled down on our automated
repayment mechanisms
uh we now offer about 15 different types
of ways for people to pay and we've done
some great deals with people like google
pay and all the big kind of upi apps
to give our customers for example
cashback when they make their repayments
so it's not just that cash is awkward
and difficult and takes time to collect
um digital payments are also better for
the customer you actually get an
economic incentive to switch to them
so yeah i think that kind of obsession
with complete automation
uh really really came into play during
that period
and we actually had you know friends and
um people in the ecosystem particularly
at traditional banks reaching out saying
can you tell us how you're collecting
can you tell us how you're still
servicing your customers what what is
this
wizardry that you guys are doing but
it's actually what we would always be
doing
but it just became more relevant during
that period
that kind of segues to another poll that
i will launch here
because you talked about the centricity
of ai
in your business so i'm going to ask um
folks if they think their future
career will involve ai
so again we'll just keep this open for
about a minute and a half
but i know that
we have few people in fintech now but
whatever
industry you're in um
what do you think your career holds with
real
uh relation to ai do you think it's
going to impact your career
do you think it's something that you're
going to need to
understand and manage
again
give about 20 more seconds
do remember to hit submit
and the poll will close in five four
three two one
just love that countdown um
yay correct answer that's good
i don't know where the other 33 were
that's pretty um pretty
um decisive i should say i guess
yeah you could say we are preaching to
the converted today
nobody is going to be on this webinar if
they don't
understand that so this is great i'm so
pleased to see that result
because that was definitely a strong
message i wanted
to leave people with which is that no
matter what role you are in right now
or what role you would like to be in i
can guarantee you
it will involve ai in the next decade
pretty much
every piece of the world of work will
touch ai
in some way i'm quite convinced of that
um so it sounds like
folks on the line already know that and
that's why they're here
so uh dovetailing with uh
your exhortation for people to consider
a uh
finance fintech as a career
yeah in the specific case of ai
and fintech do you have a couple of uh
examples or use cases of how yeah
ai powers it yes i'd love to talk about
that
um i think when we talk about ai you
know it's it's such a buzz word it's
everybody kind of throws around ml ai
uh without actually relating it to the
real world
and how it touches you and me every day
or if they do relate it
they give the classic example of you
know
you buy um a kettle on amazon and the
next day they show you an ad for a
kettle
right and people say huh how is this ai
this is ridiculous
um luckily things have advanced a lot
and in fintech there are so many
applications
and we have a central
ai strategy team uh because everybody in
the entire organization
is imbibing an ai solution to the
problems that they're facing
and this strategy team i think have some
85 different projects
on their roadmap right which touch every
part of the business and the
organization
the obvious one that fintech people
always assume
where ai comes in is in credit risk
right credit risk and underwriting
so i'm sure we've all been hearing for
the last few years
about the concept of using alternative
data to assess credit risk
and the fact that traditional lenders
will look only at things like you know
income statements income proof or
you know very traditional kind of
paper-based data
metrics of course ai is critical
in credit risk assessment and from day
zero
that was the absolute fundamental pillar
of everything that we built in our in
our
credit risk modeling so we have about 13
different credit risk models that
run on anything a single transaction
um and sometimes i explain it to people
who aren't really completely comfortable
with this this concept of using ai and
alternative data
uh they think there's a black box that
we don't really understand and it's like
the computer says yes
that's not true the way i sometimes try
and explain it is
imagine a binomial tree that just gets
more and more and more complex the more
data you at
if you had a human making a credit
decision
on the basis of that tree they could
only remember
so many nodes right after maybe 12 or
14 their head would you know explode
we can create a tree with some 10 000
data points that can all interact and
counterbalance each other
which absolutely leads to a more
accurate
and less biased credit decision so
that's one of the really powerful things
about using ai models in credit risk
the other thing that's amazing is it's
very fast so
if you're looking again at what happened
during the pandemic
we didn't have to go back to our you
know manual
underwriting team change their rules
change their training
change their policies because that takes
a long time right you'd have to have a
credit risk committee to make some
decisions
the great thing by using ai models is
you can very very quickly retrain them
right so you can give them new inputs
new course correction
and the models learn really really fast
um and one of the things that's very
relevant to our product
and to anybody that does consumer credit
or credit cards or any products like
that
is something called dynamic line
management
so basically saying you know in january
sure we wanted to lend you a hundred
dollars or
you know six thousand rupees but guess
what between january and october
your income has come down by 50 so
actually we probably only
want you to have 50 right now so how
quickly you can update that
credit line is a very very critical
thing
to reducing risk and actually making
sure your product is suitable for your
customer
at all times and again with ai models
that can be dynamic it can literally be
real time
as soon as we get some information we
can adjust the credit line up and down
so that's just one example but i wanted
to give a couple more because i think
otherwise people think that that's all
ai is
it's just it's just these black box
models um
a really cool way we use ai in our
business is in fraud detection
and actually more than two years ago
we bought a company who had been
working on apps for instagram to let you
you know pick
your favorite photo from a bunch of
photos like which
which picture looks most like you okay
and then you can post that on instagram
and we saw that technology and we
thought that could be useful
um and so we bought that company and we
incorporated the ai technology they were
using
to build a face matching algorithm
so now we can look at a selfie of a
customer and we can look at
an id document and we can very clearly
identify
if that is the actual uh identity
so that's a really small example where
sometimes a model and a machine
can be more accurate than a human being
right because we all have subjective
biases
we all know that sometimes we get people
mistaken
and then maybe just the third and final
example i'll give you is
a very boring one but very very relevant
in
anyone that does a lending business
which is the world of collections
and i say boring because people
traditionally thought it was just all
about you know
someone knocking on the door and
collecting cash um as i've said already
in our business we were never
gonna do that so again from day one we
had to create
a far more automated and ai driven
approach to collections
and we have done that and we're so proud
of what we've done there we think that
we have one of the most interesting
collection strategies to put it very
simply
our models can predict what time of day
you would be most likely to say open an
email
or answer a phone call and we will only
show you messages at that time of day
not for example when you're like picking
your kid up from school and you would be
very
harassed to see that message we would do
it at the time when we know
you are receptive that's just one
example
um but also as you'll know in india we
have a lot of complexity
geographically we have customers who
speak more than 20 languages
and so another incredible thing our
model can do
is match the right collections agent to
the right customer
because the outcome of a call is going
to be that much better
if the right agent is speaking the right
language to the right customer
so that's just a really simple example
um but i hope
that people can see that these are some
of the applications of ai in fintech
that can make a digital model
so much more effective and frankly
consumer focused right customer friendly
than the more traditional manual ways of
doing these things
which which is somewhat ironic because
we've been conditioned to think that
processes conducted by machines
are less personal less friendly and
[Music]
and you you're describing the opposite
absolutely i love that you said that no
i think you're right and i think that
um we believe strongly in always using
ai in a very
ethical and customer first way um
and it really can be you know one of the
most powerful things we can do
is genuinely know our customer through
data
and therefore we can give them a much
much better experience
and make them feel more you know special
frankly
than if we just had a one-size-fits-all
so absolutely
completely agree so i'm going to ask
the audience another poll question
because i want to see what their
opinion is compared to yours
and this poll is what do you think
what tech trend will be the biggest
disrupter
coming uh in the coming years
so
again leave this open maybe just a tiny
bit longer for people to consider
i believe this is a forced choice
question where you can pick
one
which really makes you think about
what your what your biggest
impression is of
the coming disruption in industry
and we'll close the poll in about 20
seconds
about 10.
please hit enter three two
one and
here's the full result
so
the primary answer
from people who answer interesting
rising demand for ethical ai
and trusted data so
a concern for the um
how the machines will interact with us
and and whether we can
uh rely on them to be fair and discreet
yeah no that's really interesting and
not completely surprising
uh especially with everything that's
going on in politics and
social media so i hope that i can
convince today that there is some
incredibly powerful and positive
benefits
of ai but you're right yeah i think this
is a hot topic it's something we talk
about a lot
which is this concept of ethical ai one
of the things
that we feel passionately about at zest
money is
customer data belongs only to the
customer
right it's it's your data you own it and
we actually take great offense to
companies that
kind of boost their valuation and brand
themselves as owning lots of data
because often that data doesn't belong
to them
right it actually belongs to their
consumers and
we believe that if we are going to use a
customer's data
they must consent to entrust us with it
with a very strong consent architecture
and secondly maybe more importantly um
that they understand that they're
getting a benefit
for entrusting us with their data
we must never leave it opaque or
non-transparent as to why we need that
data
so we try and make it very clear and we
don't do
some of the things that fintech
companies in in other markets do and
even in india
such as scraping your mobile phone and
taking all your contact information for
example
right we don't need to know your best
friend's
mobile phone number that's not gonna
help us i'm afraid
um and i know why maybe some some
syntax thing they do need to know that
um but we believe that the
potential cost to you of you know giving
us that data
uh is is not substantiated by the
benefit right so data and how we use
data always has to be on the basis of a
cost benefit analysis
and a conversation a real dialogue with
the customer
uh so actually i saw this gamification
as well in one of the answers and that's
um that's that's something that a lot of
fintechs are moving towards which is
almost a sort of trading system saying
if you give me you know this base level
of data
i can give you this much of my service
if you want to add on
this additional piece of data then i can
give you this much
of my service so it's a sort of trade
which is almost
you know gamer fight um but that falls
under the remit i would say of ethical
ai
right thinking about how do you create
systems and data sets that are for the
benefit of the customer not to in any
way
exploit but i'm glad i'm really pleased
to see that that's what
um that's what people are talking about
and see as the
the key concern and something that
probably is an industry
uh players like us need to be much more
vocal about and
reassure consumers that we are thinking
properly about the ethics of ai um
i think where it gets more complicated
and one of the other
attacks on ai uh but but really
important for everybody on this webinar
is to what extent does ai automate away
our jobs right and i think that's also
the
subliminal fear that that we all have
and and that's typical of any new
technology
right i think you know for for history
whenever something new comes in
there's this fear that you know when i'm
sure when the the
ford motor car came along what was going
to happen to all the horses right
there's always going to be this type of
um fear factor not realizing that we
could maybe just
have more people have transportation
right and the markets themselves will
grow and that will create its own
new employment opportunities and i think
fintech is a great example of that
so we're seeing um you know whilst we
are
driving this huge amount of automation
in our business
it's also creating a huge amount of
employment in terms of data scientists
and engineers and ai practitioners
and i'm i'm honestly saying this today
and i hope this is encouraging for folks
on the webinar but
we cannot get enough uh ai practitioners
today
it's a very there's a supply demand
mismatch in the industry
we would always always be in search
of more people for our ai teams
especially people with an engineering
background who have solved real-life
problems in an ai domain
so that creates a huge amount of new
employment
but i think we also have to believe that
a lot of the automation
and ai that we're seeing in the
workplace is also having very positive
impacts
on the world of work so i was speaking
to our hr head
today and she was telling me that we are
already
testing an ai tool um in hr
that will be able to predict how engaged
different employees are
and in a new world of work from home
this is so critical because it's so hard
to know
you know which of your team is
struggling who is
really not you know psychologically
coping up with this
this new paradigm and this tool is able
to basically
you know raise the alarm if a particular
employee becomes much more subdued and
low engagement
and low contribution so that's a
phenomenally powerful use
i think that would be very difficult to
replicate and that's not taking away
anyone's job
right there's nobody that would be able
to do that without the tool
so i think that's a really good example
um
similarly you're seeing you know all
sorts of different processes in the
workplace being automated by ai models
and means that you can actually do more
interesting things
right so we can launch new products new
experiences more quickly for our
customers
it doesn't mean that we you know take
away from a job that somebody was always
doing
i think where it gets really interesting
though is in the world of engineering
and i do wonder in 10 years if we will
have
you know traditional coding uh
teams you know all this rush to teach
our children to code
and every every new ed tech startup in
india is teaching children coding at the
age of
six months now i wonder if those skills
will eventually be redundant because
it's very easy now
to create these apprentice ai models
that a good engineer can train up to do
a lot of the most basic
um code that they do every day again i
don't think that removes necessarily
uh the pool of of employees but it
changes what you need to do to be
competitive
in the workplace now so you need to keep
kind of
rising up and aiming higher um because
certainly at that lower level
you could see a bot taking your job
yeah in fact i'm
working on an article for our website
about the digital workforce
and some people think that the digital
workforce literally is a workforce made
up of digital
bots and apps right but
clearly what what it refers to
is a digitally enhanced or enabled
force where as you said there are jobs
that can be better
done by machines and when they're done
by machines that frees up
people to do yeah people are interesting
stuff
exactly exactly and this is such an
important point
um when we when we promote and hire
you know leaders in our company it's not
because of how accurate their code is
right it's because they inspire motivate
and lead other people in the business to
do good work
so again only for a very short period of
your life will
your pure technical skills be the most
important thing increasingly
um everything else about you becomes
more important
so there's something wonderful about ai
freeing you up
from a lot of the day-to-day work and
drudgery of your
your job i mean i remember you know my
first job i'm guessing for you as last
year there was a lot of boring stuff i
had to photocopy things you know
all day long and that doesn't happen
anymore so i get to do more fun work
and so i think that's just a good
example i know that
um microsoft are working on uh a
software that kind of
prompts like an auto correct you know is
this what you meant
to code and that's great because people
could probably finish their work that
would take
you know eight hours in two what's wrong
with that more time for
for life
um so we talked about the mismatch of
supply and demand
and that's one of the things we want to
emphasize to our audience is
to become part of the supply what uh
what ai and data science related skill
sets
should someone look to acquire
if they want a successful career in a
fintech company like yours
or in the industry great question
yeah skill job they're most in demand
yeah and it it'll fall broadly into
abilities and aptitudes right and i
would say
that let's not skim over the aptitudes
because especially
in any emerging industry like fintech
your your aptitude and your attitude and
your
kind of willingness to just try new
things
will end up being probably more
important than the specific skill set
that you have
but saying that i would say that um
there's especially in ai there's a lot
of people we see a lot of candidates we
see today
who i would call ai enthusiasts
so maybe they had a role in like product
management or marketing
and then they just did a certification
in ai
and now that they think they can kind of
run you know
ml models that's not realistic i think
it's really important that people still
focus on the fundamentals
so the further they can go with
a very traditional engineering you know
apprenticeship
effectively even if they start out in
you know a large company doing something
that looks completely boring and
unrelated
but get very very strong good uh
coding skills in different languages
brilliant star
and then obviously you know the basics
like sql how to
work with data sets how to build data
lakes data curation
just get familiar with the basics right
and any large
tech employer um we'll be working on
that basis today
um i would also say as soon as possible
when you can get your hands on real life
problems right so rather than working in
this kind of enthusiast
zone you know don't don't go and be like
the ai expert
in a very traditional business right
they won't be using
your your skills actually go into a
business
that is ai first and get your hands
dirty
really get your hands dirty get involved
in real life projects
um get to know the business inside out
so that you can work out where could ai
really solve a problem right it would
have
been impossible for a ai
guru to look at a business like ours and
and figure out this face matching
phenomenon right that's not obvious but
once somebody had been
you know deeply embedded in our fraud
and risk team for many years
they could instantly recognize when they
saw you know an instagram app
this would help with fraud so i would
say the
the certifications and the taglines that
you use to say that you
are ai qualified are much less important
than the real life problems you have
solved
using ai in an organization so so start
with the basics
it's okay to start in a more traditional
engineering role quickly move into
a company or department where you can
solve real problems um
and then and then again i have to
reiterate that um
[Music]
attitude is everything right things are
moving so quickly
and one of the biggest uh negatives i've
seen in people that we've
into you
is even world and what you know
it's my way or the highway um and i
think especially in anything
as fast paced as ai right you have to be
open-minded and you have to appreciate
that you will learn on the job a lot
will be happening quickly and keep
keep up to date do webinars you know
go to conferences um even follow there's
some incredible
you know handles on twitter on linkedin
just
just keep learning keep educating
yourself
um so yeah that would be the sort of
broad brush i would just find a point i
would say
if you are at the very early stage of
your career
and you know that you want to be a real
kind of ai expert and you're deciding
whether to be
a sort of business economics or data
specialist versus an engineer
i would probably say go down the
engineer path and then
sideways because we definitely find it's
easier to train an
engineer in the data side than the other
way around
that's an interesting point um
i wonder why that is exactly by the way
it's it's one of those things where
you think as you mentioned earlier
everybody's trying to teach their
children to code
so you would think that somebody with
the data science background could pick
up the engineering skills
and you're saying it's the other way
around i guess what i'm saying is
coding is going to become like like you
know speaking a language
right it's going to become a base level
uh expected you know characteristic
uh but how quickly you can then kind of
jump up and go beyond that
depends on your understanding of
businesses
so um an engineer who's obsessed and
fascinated by business
is the dream combination um but it's not
impossible to go the other way around uh
yeah and that's i mean that's also a
really important point which is
even the best best best engineers that
we've hired
um can be stumped when they don't really
understand the intricacies of the
business
and so you know almost a kind of average
engineer
but with a real thirst and hunger to
understand how our business works
is is going to be 10 times more valuable
than a rock star
you know superstar coder um business
understanding and just
and just interest and you know inquiry
i would say are probably the most
important uh skills once you're
in the job especially okay
we do have uh one comment to the chat
lizzie could you repeat what you said to
do with twitter and linkedin
does that ring a bell i think one of
yeah i just said that um you know in
this day and age we're so lucky
that we can become experts just by
following some of the right voices
in the world so i can share afterwards
but some of the twitter handles that i
follow who are just
you know really interesting people at
google who are working on
interesting you know problems i've been
following some really interesting
people in the autonomous car space uh
not elon musk he's not very good on
twitter
people who are really you know experts
you follow him for something else um but
you know people they're real experts in
their domain and what they will
then do is do is you will get you know
access
through them to really interesting blogs
uh events that you would have heard of
otherwise so i'd say
don't we it's so easy to say that social
media isn't
is a menace and a distraction but if you
use it smartly and if you follow the
right people
and block out the noise um it's one of
the best ways to keep yourself educated
in in ai i would say yeah yeah i think
what you just said and what you your
answer the previous question
i think addresses this next question
that i had so i don't
know that we need to go into it in
detail but um
do you have specific advice that relates
to what someone in the fintech industry
or financial services industry needs to
do
to stay relevant yeah probably the same
actually which is
you know make sure that you understand
both business
context and the world of evolving ai and
ml
right and i think especially in in banks
that's really tough
because the business context and the way
it's operating today will be very far
removed from what you're reading and
hearing about when you begin
you know going deep into the worlds of
ai so
i would say the sooner you can work for
fintech the better um
and every every company is becoming a
fintech now so that's very easy
especially in india
uh but yeah i'd say you know don't be
scared
a few years ago you know working in a
bank or a traditional financial services
firm
was considered a job for life that was
never going to be a bad
career move and i think we will all be
shocked
by how quickly that changes i think
people will be really surprised
by how redundant
traditional banks become not
in the sense that they're going to go
out of business but just in the scope of
what they do
right eventually most banks all over the
world
will be the storage of capital and the
regulatory
you know interface but the front end and
the way that
customers touch financial products will
all be tech driven
so if you're really fascinated by ai and
technology
but you want to work in the financial
services industry you may as well just
go straight to a tech company or a
fintech i would say
you won't necessarily get the baptism in
a bank
but that and i've worked on all sides so
i'm being i'm trying to be balanced
so yeah i mean
it's been a long time since i've had to
touch my checkbook which is
to make payments but i use paypal every
day
so there you go there you go and that's
just become
even more relevant in the last six
months right so
and i think also you know specific to
india but
we really are accelerating at such a
faster pace
than any other market has done before uh
in this way
when it comes to digital finance and so
you could even see things
emerging here that the rest of the world
had never dreamt of
so it's even more important to stay
ahead of the curve if you're if you're
in india and graduating today
okay um looking ahead if you're going to
look five years down the road
what would a career in fintech
look like for a data science or ai
professional
i hope um it looks like i guess my
career which is
uh very engaging extremely engaging so
i i would say i can't remember the last
time i felt bored
in my work right i am i'm constantly
stimulated
engaged and learning engaging um and
then impactful
right i somebody asked me the other day
what
really really motivates you right what
really makes you want to do this
every morning and when i really broke it
down and kept asking why why why
it was because i felt i was having a
really positive impact
on people and an industry okay and at
the end of the day
that is what matters that's that's going
to be your legacy
that's going to be how you sleep at
night you know having a positive impact
on other people is one of the most
beautiful and you know powerful things
you could have in your career
um people in the media i i read once
that
hairdressers are the happiest people
that's the happiest career hairdressers
because some 10 times a day someone says
oh thank you i look amazing so impact is
really important
and make sure you're having a positive
impact on the world or somebody
um and then i guess the third one i'd
say is is evergreed
meaning don't get sidelined don't get
stuck down
a niche that becomes you know
irrelevant over time make sure that
whatever you're doing you are constantly
learning
and constantly um you know evolving
and trying new things and actually if
you look at you know myself or
my co-founders and many of the founders
and entrepreneurs that
are friends of mine we did not
have a straight straight-line career our
careers were quite sideways sometimes
right
so i remember leaving a very cushy
well-paid
investment job whereas investing lots of
money and
staying in five-star hotels and i went
into
a startup right almost in in day zero it
was very early stage at that time in
london
and it felt like a real you know i
didn't even have a desk
i used to have to sit on a windowsill
and use my laptop
and i thought what have i done this is
crazy but
that opportunity got me to india and
building some incredible businesses in
india so
um don't be scared to sometimes go
sideways a really
interesting career in fintech often will
have that um
but you can then make big leaps in the
future
um so i think yeah i think it's gonna be
one of the most interesting domains for
the next decade
i still think that we're on day zero in
fintech
i you say paypal but paypal is one of
the only
mega uh highly valued fintech companies
that has come out right
still all the big banks you know
jpmorgans the
bank of america these companies are
still worth
multiples of any fintech company today
and i do not believe that will be the
case in a decade
which means over the next 10 years a
huge
amount of value creation is going to
happen in fintech
and literally millions of jobs will be
created
in domains and products that we can't
even imagine today
because we're going to rewrite the way
the industry works
what worked in the past isn't going to
work today and we're a good example at
zest
we are obsessed with the concept of uh
kill the card
we think credit cards are a terrible
business model
um they were designed for the 1950s
they are not relevant today to young
people who use mobile phones
and so we're designing you know
alternative products to credit cards
but that will happen in every single
piece of the traditional finance
industry so you know it's
impossible to even imagine what a career
will look like in five years or ten
years
in fintech because so much is being
built it's like the
you know imagine the kind of first days
of building the railroads
in america it's we're literally like
that we're just laying down the tracks
there's going to be so much um
innovation and exciting evolution in the
next decade
yeah and one of the things that's
interesting about
uh when you're laying down the tracks um
you have to send people out in front to
scout out
the unknown territory yes that makes it
even more
risky exactly that's a great point
actually that's a really good point
uh we talk about this a lot at zest as
well which is
you know get rid of that fear of failure
because anything fantastic did not come
from a space of fear right
and if you look at the amount of
near-misses that google have had i think
they've had you know 10 times more
products that didn't work
uh compared to the ones that have worked
but that's why they're so fantastic
today so
um especially in fintech and it's it's
tough because a lot of people from a
traditional finance
background are scared of failure because
it sometimes has you know regulatory
penalties and things like that
but for us to truly build those those uh
those tracks we need to fail as well and
be comfortable with that
um hopefully we've in this discussion
inspired some people to consider fintech
as a career choice so i'm going to open
this poll
and ask people why they would want to
pursue a career in fintech
i think there are some strong reasons
there and i think you can pick more than
one in this bowl
leave this open for a minute or two
nice
it's certainly a place to be
impactful in people's lives we talked
about
how you view uh
zest money is having the potential to
impact 300 million people's lives
absolutely that's what keeps us going
yeah and certainly a great place for
people who like to solve
challenging problems i would never for
example
never would have made the connection
between an instagram app
and uh a fintech business
in in the way that you did so
all right i'm gonna close the poll in
about 20 seconds here
about 10 seconds to get your answers in
results are kind of interesting here oh
yeah
oh completely split
yeah it's you'd think that um
people might look at that and say you
know it's a kind of a cool industry
i see square and yeah
the us is square and paypal
and a bunch of other
high profile unicorn companies but
that's not what's motivating our
audience our audience are looking at
those
things like um great
impact and problems
i i have to say that's very millennial i
love
i love this it's very classic but
brilliant
brilliant to see very good uh
so at this point i think we can move on
to
um our question and answer period
and what i'm gonna do is um we've been
collecting the questions
and i'm going to go through a few of
them one of them is from
uh let's see
we have a question from ed from our
youtube channel
who asks uh i'd like to open a fintech
startup
what what guidance would you give oh wow
that's great uh do it um
i think you know there there's there's
so much
that needs to be built that whatever
your idea is i'm sure there's going to
be a space for it
uh but do do your research i think
fintech is
one where you can't really kind of be an
amateur i guess
i don't mean that in a patronizing way
but the the
um amount of domain
knowledge that you need even just to get
investors to trust you
um and then the amount of understanding
of regulation that you need
will determine your success so i would
say uh
i want everybody here today to want to
run a fintech company
but i would also caution that you
definitely need to do
um a lot of homework and definitely
don't
jump into something just because it's a
wide open space
you may discover uh there's a good
reason for that i.e a huge
you know regulatory risk or something
like that
but no otherwise i would say go ahead
and let me know
if i can invest or help
question from fenindra
who asks what are some of the
unconventional
features or data points you considered
when you build the model
that predicts uh credit risk or personal
default risk yeah i'm always a bit
boring on this topic
because um i've heard other lending
companies say you know we we think that
people with
dogs or people you know pets are
predictive of credit risk honestly none
of that's true
um unfortunately we have found pretty
obvious things uh but let me give you a
couple of examples
um a very obvious one is how
long do you spend shopping before you
take out a loan right so if you shop
around if you even come back a few times
over a few days
if you compare prices you tend to be
a i mean first of all less likely to be
a fraudster
right so that's that's a good thing but
you tend to be a better risk and linked
to that
we do have um one data point which is
did you read the terms and conditions
fully right i don't know how many of you
have you know there's a new app update
and you just like
yeah yeah click click click i've read it
i've read it but you haven't
when you're taking out a financial
product especially one that involves you
know
credit lending repayments you must read
the terms and conditions i think we all
know that because
you you know you need to know what
you're paying what could be the risks
um and so customers who don't uh not
surprisingly are found to be
you know riskier characters so those are
like really boring examples i'm not
going to pretend that we look at your
facebook feed and see how many friends
you have
because we don't it's not predictive i'm
sorry it's not
okay um cairo asks
what technology tools do you use for ai
it's just funny
yeah everything a lot a lot i mean it
depends right because we have
um we have about 40 engineers working on
different ai solutions so
you know again it's back to this point
right we don't we don't just have an ai
bubble we have an ai application across
everything that we do
so whether it's you know um
a front-end marketing app that will have
an element of ai in it
uh all the way down to our core risk
engines which will be extremely
extremely complex uh model systems
there's a lot of python on the back end
i think we mentioned that really so
python is a very important code for
anybody in ai and then obviously a lot
of
you know cloud-based data systems but i
don't really
give any preferential branding names to
any
any any software organizations but yeah
you can imagine have an interesting
question
from sunny who asks
which do you feel is more important
understanding a business problem or
solving it
oh i love that oh and that's actually
that's quite a hot debate in uh the
world of product management we
we debate this a lot internally meaning
the business person or the sort of owner
of that problem
should ideally lay out the problem so
articulately that an
engineer can solve it you shouldn't have
a situation where business owners
are devising their own problems and
their own solutions
and then telling engineers what to build
and we've worked really hard
to create the opposite right to create a
system where
um the business people are there to
articulate problems but the engineers
and the ai team are there to solve them
so i guess the hard answer is for you
folk for the
ai team it's important to be able to do
both right
for the business people it's more
important to be able to articulate the
problem
uh but yeah i think you need experience
on both sides that's a great question
it's quite philosophical i might have to
sleep on that a
webinar with a decision scientist at
salesforce who pointed out that the
business team
comes with problems they want the
technical
people to solve the technical team comes
with
solutions solutions looking for a
problem
and and that um you know in their view
it's critical to make sure that that is
a two-way communication
yeah you know sometimes not knowing that
a solution is possible
limits your thinking about the problem
that's a really good point
that's really good i think there's
entire businesses that vc's fund that i
would
define as a problem looking for a
solution
so and that's always really
disappointing in the long run
so it's probably better in hindsight
than to to know your problems
as much as your solutions
i think we have a number of questions um
that have to do with moving into ai from
either engineering or from outside from
financial background
or from outside either of those
so what what steps would you you advise
somebody to take
to yeah move into that
uh and we i mean again i guess i would
say go and get your hands dirty as
quickly as possible
um apply like mad to every every
tech on the block we are very
open-minded about
the type of people that we hire right so
we are we again as i said we look more
for
aptitudes rather than skills only so i
wouldn't say be
be put off but if you can doing an
internship you know even like for a few
months
inside a company is not a bad idea
because it gives you time to also
understand their culture and if it's
you know the right fit for you um the
other thing i'd say is
people are everything right so you know
who
you work for can sometimes be as
important as the problem you're solving
so back to my twitter point and maybe do
some stalking
of the industry you're interested in
find some of the leading
experts right so i would say you know
there's a couple of people at zest
that are absolutely top of their game in
in what they do one lady called natalya
i think she's probably one of
a handful of people in the world who can
build these underwriting scorecards
in in in an ml format um
you know you should if you're interested
in that vertical
you should be following her and you know
hounding her and sending her interesting
articles
um and she might just see something
really exciting in that and and say come
in and let's
you know work on a project together so
try and identify people
that could help you make that transition
not just
the company um
somebody uh davon asks
is the commercial lending space in
fintech already crowded
good question no great opportunity
uh i would say a lot of the fintech
focus especially in india in the last
few years has been
almost completely on the consumer there
have been some
sme and micro sme fintechs that have
done really well
but anything bigger than that and
anything on say like
factoring or the more traditional side
of of commercial lending
very little innovation right now that's
still the domain of the big bank
certainly in india
so that would be a brilliant brilliant
place and i think that
is so timely because that's exactly the
type of domain
where it was assumed you could get by
without automation
and covid has proven that you really let
down your clients
right at that time so i think you will
find that banks will be trying to
automate
their commercial side of their business
very quickly right now so huge
opportunity
would strongly recommend that yeah okay
um i think we have reached the end of
our hour so
oh no i want to apologize but to
everyone who submitted questions that we
could not get to
um and there are quite a few but great
questions
thank you we really want to thank you
lizzy for
uh thank you thank you for those and
um thank you for being with us today
this has been a really wonderful
conversation
thank you i'm going to um
go back and show a couple of finishing
slides but i did want to
let people know how they might be able
to get
in touch with you on linkedin or other
social channels
so there's your linkedin information are
there other
twitter yeah twitter yeah yeah follow me
on twitter i think it's at
chapman lizzie just search for lizzie
chapman on twitter i think you'll find
me
yeah yeah definitely and i'll try and
share more
interesting stuff
this has been a wonderful conversation
and
um very enjoyable
thank you for having me really enjoyed
it
do you want um show
a brief announcement of a program that
we have
simply learned called skill up and skill
up is a way to access
a number of our basic courses for
free over 300
skills um and over a thousand hours of
video content
and so these are different from our
traditional courses and that these don't
include the
virtual classroom component but they do
allow you to get a
basic understanding of the different
topics
and that includes data science and ai
as well as many more so you can see that
i think i've posted the link and i will
again post the link in the chat
but it's skill up free online courses at
simplylearn.com and our next
webinar will be one week from today
it will also involve ai and
it's a job search in the world of ai
recruitment secrets and resume
tips revealed for 2021 which is uh
something about how you can
try to align your resume
with what the ai engines are
looking to to highlight so you couldn't
verma of cut short will be our guest
then and you can
connect with simply learn on our social
channels facebook twitter and linkedin
i want to thank everybody for being here
today
and we hope that you have enjoyed it and
learned from it as
much as i have
again thank you to lizzy and this
concludes the webinar
thank you bye bye
bye
you